you know you're living out here in Los
Angeles where are you living I live out
Malibu because I'm rich and Malibu
that's that's pretty swanky out there
that's nice nice but it's not perfect
why not other people have access to the
beach well wow what a way to endear you
to the people around you oh it's like
what's the point you know but the thing
is like it's nice and I like it you know
I've been in show business for thirty
years I finally you know a dream of mine
you're always in the back of my mind
well one day you'll get a place on the
beach you know and you think that would
be perfect but it's not Conan Mandy yes
because like I said I got this the last
two weeks this is a guy I'm just
assuming he's a crazy homeless guy but
he's coming there cuz he looks like your
crazy homeless guy he's come and he
comes and he's literally takes down his
pants in front of my house at sunset and
starts you know whacking away you know
like and you don't you mean pleasuring
himself he's pleasuring himself yeah and
he's not even facing the sunset which is
more beautiful he's facing my house like
in two weeks of the puppies knows the
lighting for him is better that way yeah
but finally I'm looking at then I know
it's like I said okay one day two to two
weeks of this so finally I go out there
and I'm not stupid I bring my I brought
my pitbull because you know the some of
these homeless guys can fight right nice
right so I got out there and I say hey
listen pal and I got a little louder
because I got my dog with me yeah listen
pal I didn't spend 30 years in show
business you know to like to watch a
sunset with your wanker in it you know
yeah and and then that's the weird thing
but you never know what what life's
gonna throw you and he said this to me
he said you know I used to be in the
record business back in the early 90s
those are good times you know 16 bucks a
CD boy I never thought it was gonna end
but did end let me tell you though you
know the wife you know it's easy to
upscale but not easy to downscale and
then it went all the way and she
couldn't handle it she left and then I
just started vibing and I didn't stop
and no anyway I used to live in that
house right there your house that's a
that's a bummer yeah I felt bad
yeah and I felt bad you know and I got
the dog there you know and and I felt
bad I said that's why I get it you know
you you things were good times and then
you fell on bad times and then you you
go get high and then you come over you
look at the house you get excited you
start you know yeah and then and then he
said no your wife takes a shower
[Applause]
[Music]
you